[Music]
good morning John it's Friday November
2nd
I'm windows Dusk's because I'm in
Englewood Florida and Englewood Florida
is very much a part of Old Port and by
that I don't mean that it is an old part
of Florida I mean it's one of the parts
of Florida where almost everyone is very
old and so I wanted to fit in but I know
that there are some nerdfighters here
and I also know that nerdfighters always
make the most of situations that they're
in do your best and if you are in
Englewood I have a surprise for you at
the end of the video anyway now it's
tough for me to put in the stuff that I
taped this morning back into the video
you may be confused because my hair will
be longer and my shirt will be orange er
but it was all taped today
now that Mondo's gave me a haircut I'm
very confused I'm not sure which secret
sibling you're talking about when you
saying she's dating a prominent
nerdfighter are you saying like I got an
actor but then you never help with
buying train tickets so they're probably
not famous but I'm willing to help
hundred dollars I think the foundation
to decrease worldsuck and do that more
importantly John I have something that I
need to show you in fact I need to show
everyone
preferably everyone in the entire world
I'm pretty excited about it so on one
day I wrote a book that you wrote called
it just isn't fair and I recently
discovered that book was a recipient of
the Orange County Public Schools young
authors award and what that means is
that you got to go to a special little
conference with about special kids and
it also means the dad was there with the
video camera these are the two winners
from Audubon Park Elementary School some
little girl with a book about her bird
and John Green who apparently was told
to smile and took it a little too
seriously
and then all the kids got together in
writers groups and they read each other
their books here's a little excerpt
now I want everyone to watch closely
here John's teacher asks a question and
then there is a long pause then a little
girl speaks I want everyone to keep
their eyes on John's face while the
little girl speaks and after the little
girl speaks that moment
he felt it the muse entered John Green
it is not left since she felt the little
eight-year-old version of the ecstasy
that you can get from being appreciated
for something that you creates and that
little girl saying that she liked it and
that it seemed kind of like real life is
the reason John Green is a writer today
John I am proud of you in your adorable
little face but now you all know now
you've seen it seen the moment when it
happened the moment amazing that it was
captured on film amazing John I'll see
you tomorrow
hmm blonde past Parkin Angola Florida I
wonder what could be under this rock